[Music]
we're counting down to a giant leap
forward in the billionaire space race
virgin galactic's richard branson and
blue origin chef bezos are both
launching
this month on separate missions branson
is scheduled to be first this sunday
mark strossman is in new mexico ahead of
the historic flight
mark good morning hey vlad good morning
to you behind me you can see a replica
of virgin galactic's space vehicle it
looks different
because it is different it's a
rocket-powered space plane
and for the company this will be the
fourth trip into space
but the first to carry its founder
astronaut 001 richard branson
i'll be evaluating the customer space
flight experience
give sir richard branson this much the
swashbuckling billionaire has a knack
for making his dreams seem like ours in
this case
space he believes it's for everyone
do you like the term space tourism yeah
space tourism works
on sunday morning branson will become
the space tourist
since 2004 his company virgin galactic
has persevered through test flights and
setbacks
like an accident in 2014 that killed
a test pilot space definitely is hard
we've had our tears we've had our joys
but i tell you what the joys
have been fantastic branson space
voyaging will begin
on a runway this runway at spaceport
america in new mexico
a 12 thousand foot straightaway for
virgin galactic's mother ship
vms eve is a plane a twin fuselage
aircraft
with two pilots in the middle
it carries the space plane vss unity
three two one release release release
at about forty five thousand feet eve
will release
unity fire fire the space ship will
shoot straight up
more than fifty miles where space begins
we've got massive windows all the way
around they'll be able to unbuckle
they'll be able to float around
and they will become an astronaut
branson and three other passengers
all employees should experience a few
minutes of weightlessness
then unity's two pilots will glide
everyone
back to earth we really are going to be
a hub for space tourism for sub-orbital
flight
scott mclaughlin oversees spaceport
america
nerves are a part of it nerves are part
of it yeah and anybody who says
otherwise is
yeah this is going to space virgin
galactic moved its operations here in
2019.
the nearest city is named truth or
consequences
i asked mclaughlin for a little of both
about the risks involved
that's the key factor right it has to be
safe this is the moment of truth both
for
virgin galactic and for this facility i
think so i think it'd be hard to argue
that it's not
branson's rival as a space baron jeff
bezos
he'll launch in his blue origin
spaceship on july 20th
branson will beat bezos into space by
nine days
do you see blue origin as a competitor
yes we may be competing but
we're not really competing for
passengers because there'll be plenty
people who want to be astronauts who'll
sign up to both of us
the company has a waiting list of 600
people
eager to fly they've paid up to a
quarter million dollars a piece for that
chance
and if sunday's flight goes well they
may start flying as soon as next year
and maybe one day it'll be the jacopo
family
i would love that to be the case you
mentioned truth or consequences mark how
about truth or dare
would you go up having covered this for
years now
the strassman family i had
i don't know about the strasbourne
family i i would only ever dare speak
for myself never for my wife
but i would uh i'll tell you this much i
have a pretty healthy appetite for risk
and so yeah you bet i would i would
definitely give it a shot
bravo i appreciate that honesty mark
thank you very much
vlad jamie what do you guys think i
would totally do it yeah i haven't seen
the grand canyon yet i haven't been
underwater this explore the bering
straits i mean there's a lot to do on
planet earth
and i also don't have that kind of money
well that's true these guys are
competitive but
branson said he'd love to have jeff
bezos come and see the flight off on
sundays
i want branson to sell the star trek-y
looking sp flight suit that he wants i
know i was expecting to hear aerosmith
as i saw him walk it down the hallway
guys get the reference where would i
wear it anywhere
you know wear it to bed wear it
downstairs for coffee